kim kardashian putting her biggest asset
on display exposing her backside
sporting a jock strap on the cover of
interview magazine's american dream
issue
my american dream is
i don't know is it ready to be like i
feel like i'm living it living it up in
this platinum blonde do with bleached
eyebrows yeah bible it's a great look
but the cover isn't the only revealing
part of this spread kim also lets it all
hang out in her interview with the mag
and yes she talks pete davidson and
kanye west he inspired me too because
he's so confident and he would always
build up my confidence
to be who i want to be kim continues to
pay yay his dues praising her estranged
ex for helping elevate her career she
tells interview she felt like she really
arrived in high society thanks to the
rapper
he was introducing me to a lot of people
i think that definitely got a lot of
people to have a different level of
respect but that's it kim doesn't dive
deeper into the easy maker's recent
behavior which includes online digs at
kim's parenting and family when i think
that there's something that you know is
maybe done wrong or even if the
messaging's right maybe it the
communication isn't quite there to
figure that out but i always believe and
trust in him that he will
always eventually explain himself
because i know his heart kanye's also
laid into kim's last relationship with
pete davidson
he's just super genuine yeah and it's
just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do
nothing and while the two have since
parted ways kim's got nothing but praise
for the snl comedian telling the mag
he's a cutie he's literally such a good
person they don't really make them like
him anymore i'm excited for what he has
coming up pete is has got to be
literally the best human being i've ever
met like the best heart people always
say like oh he's so funny and it's like
has to do with how funny he is that's
like
fourth on my list of why i like him
always wants the best for people can
handle
anything
always does it with grace now it's
unclear if kim spoke with the interview
before or after breaking things off with
pete you just gotta roll with it what we
do know is kim is rolling into a new
chapter
also sharing that she's launching a new
project a true crime podcast i have
always been really fascinated with
crime true crime the law
i'm really motivated to get to know the
law more and fight for people that
deserve a second chance it seems kim is
bringing her passion for writing the
wrongs of the justice system to modern
day radio with a show called the system
and she's got quite the tease for the
first season about a really crazy case
where a guy got the death sentence for a
triple homicide that happened in ohio
there are so many twists and turns with
how it was handled or mishandled and we
take the listener along for a journey in
search of the truth safe to say the mom
of force keeping busy having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot
and yet she's open to adding even more
to her plate confessing she'd be down to
film a marvel movie if the offer came
her way saying quote things come when
they're supposed to
it'll happen when it's meant to be
[Music]